ça te rappelle quelque chose
la patte de lapin ou tél
je voulais donner tort
oui la patte de lapin
pourquoi vous dit ça c'était pas avec ce
je vais compter jusqu'à 10
et tu vas me dire ou es la patte de
lapin ou aylmer
je lui ai tout va bien aller tout va
bien aller sur 3
alors écoutez moi j'ai eu exactement ce
que vous aviez demandé ce que vous
vouliez autre chose
ce qu'il ya eu un malentendu je peut
arranger ça je vous l'aurais tout ce que
vous voulez
voter par les moines on peut discuter
comme des gens bien élevés
d'accord
je sais où est votre patte de lapin
je vais vous aider comme tu m'as était
dans l'avion
comme ça
d'abord vous lâcher ce flingue je parte
pas avec vous comme ça c'est ton choix
l'autre
la patte de lapin est à paris vous
voulez savoir où à paris alors lâché là
parce que vous n'avez pas jamais
je vais vous la voir mais si vous la
tuer si vous faites ça vous n'aurez mais
enfin tout témoin le seul moyen pour
vous de voir ce que vous voulez c'est
je vais le faire ouais la jupe oui la
patte de la g
mais tu as well as orléans s'est
assagi depuis
je jure devant dieu vous et
je vous en prie ne faites pas ça relâché
je vous le promets
je vous le promets je peux savoir
comment neuf jeux
écoutez écoutez moi
je veux vous aider je vais vous aider à
obtenir ce que vous voulez mais vous
devez faire ce qui est juste
ce que vous savez qu'il faut faire
non
bougez plus
lisez ça lentement
lisez ça
le plaisir de voir busby faire des
bêtises d'état comparables
elle met un clou sur la chaise de
messieurs si quand elle le traite à
d'horribles petit diard
je pense sur ses trouvailles de dernière
heure pour effet ce que c'est que ces
conneries finissez
faut-il va avoir de la visite finissez
me sortir de ma torpeur chalet
alpin qui me reçoit le gardent l'entrée
delta requins le une fois du temps ces
contes arts il est déjà dans le hall
[Musique]
est-ce que tout va bien monsieur non
tout ne va pas bien la voix du masque
est toujours en compilation faut 30
secondes
monsieur
[Musique]
monsieur g
6 secondes je télécharge
tombeur ces bonbons
ça va attendait dehors
et donne 100 dollars
[Musique]
tu peux pas
oh
[Musique]
tous
je
[Musique]
et
bien
j'ai acquis la charge dans ta tête
et reste au maximum quatre pilotes
gt dit qu'elle créera tournoi
bien toi je t'ai dit je te tuerais
devant ses yeux
je vais la tuer devant evian
[Musique]
et
le
quoi
[Applaudissements]